check to dole vaccinated I'm gonna
places where the iris or pick something
better make sure we're okay yep it
sounds like okay that is plenty loud
okay
let's go
can everybody hear me I can hear myself
that's a little distracting
so uh hi everybody I'm standing in for
bill today he's in Florida with his with
his mom and since I invited the speaker
bill asked me to introduce him so this
is joel worrall did I say that Rachel
okay so joel is the chief technology
officer at an organization called cure
international and his title of his talk
today is called hospital run the
challenges and opportunities of a
cloud-based EHR in the developing world
so cure internationals been around since
about nineteen ninety six and they've
been focused on delivering healthcare in
the developing world they operate
hospitals and programs in about 29
countries and are focused on surgical
care and specialties that include
orthopedics neurosurgery reconstructive
surgery and maternity care they treat
patients in underserved areas where
their physical disabilities can be
corrected or alleviated through medical
intervention and they treat patients
regardless of gender ethnic background
or religious affiliation joel has a BS
in computer science from messiah college
and a master's of religion and Old
Testament and the ancient Near East from
evangelical theological seminary since
1999 he's been working in internet based
technologies delivering supporting
selling software as an architect
executive and consultant as I mentioned
he's currently the chief technology
officer acker international and leads
their marketing technology creative and
care kids Joel and his team are working
on open platforms and open source
communities to help pioneer ways for
software and technology business
principles and tools to influence the
way charitable work is both conducted
and supported he's currently the project
manager for hospital run which will be
hearing about today and he lives with
his lovely wife and two daughters in
Mechanicsburg Pennsylvania and I know
I'm also supposed to say there's a
hashtag if anyone's listening on the
stream they can send a question does
anyone know what that hashtag is demise
comp and someone will be monitoring it
okay thanks so much to all afternoon
good morning happy march to everybody so
see if
I'm not going to move my presentation
there I'm going to move it over here and
going to run it let's see hopefully
that's going to work out for us right so
as Steve said presentation is titled
hospital run which is the open source
project running the challenges and
opportunities of intuitive cloud-based
health records in the developing world
Steve already said this but a little bit
about me so I'm a coder computer nerd
who happens to be working for an
international charity and is found
myself as a part of an open source
project that's focused on health based
information systems I am NOT coming in
here as an expert right so like I'm a
practitioner I'm a student of all the
things that I'm involved in so there's
no cloak of like thority like in this in
this conversation but I mean we're doing
some pretty interesting stuff and I've
been studying this work for six and a
half years which would have been doing
with my life for 60 hours a week okay so
just a little outline on what we're
going to talk about the day I would
encourage recommend interruptions it'll
make it I don't think I'm not
interesting enough to listen to for now
i'm not sure if anyone is and so feel
free to like ask questions if i don't
want to answer it i'll just say i want
to talk about it later or if I just
don't know i'll say so so we're going to
go through i do want to cover a little
bit more about who we are as a
international organization because it
has a lot of bearing on the way we're
approaching problems some analysis that
we did around like existing options when
it comes to what we could do for health
record solutions go over some of the
challenges that come about with trying
to pursue more sophisticated technology
solutions in developing world context
and then the opportunities that's the
flip side and I don't know if I'm an
optimist but I think this job is making
me want of doing this kind of work
couple technical details I'm not going
to like drive down into the code but
like just kind of explain a little bit
about how we're actually delivering the
solution and then just a little bit on
early results so for starters here
international as a platform for
innovation so this is the map of the
locations around the world that chair
international operates so we were
started in 1996 by an orthopedic surgeon
and his wife who after coming into a
significant amount of wealth decided to
pour the majority of what they had into
the care of disabled children and so
they've done a lot of short-term work
where the doctor had gone over and done
a lot of like pretty sophisticated
surgical care thought there were some
pretty systemic problems with a short
term surgical model when it comes to
like long-term follow-up with a lot of
these cases that can be pretty
complicated I don't think any of us in
this room would want the doctor that was
that just operated on our kid to leave
town tomorrow so what would it mean to
like really be more institutional about
the way we approach some of these
problems so innovations kind of always
been a part of who the organization's
been just as an example so we've got
hospitals in 10 countries Kenya Uganda
the Dominican Republic the Philippines
we have a really strange scenario with a
facility on the edge of Oman and the
United Arab Emirates nazare which a very
very resource constrained environment
Ethiopia Zambia Afghanistan and then
Malawi we do more than that though we're
also the largest provider of infant club
foot care in the world so I'm going to
assume everybody has some sense of like
what club foot is as a congenital
deformity and maybe we all know it's the
most common congenital for me in the
world completely treatable through
Ponseti method and so we run a network
in 20 countries of nationwide clinics
where anybody can go and receive care
their kids can go through the casting
process and you know where the boots at
night and theoretically like if you
follow the treatment protocol you're
going to be okay
that cost us like maybe 400 bucks to be
able to take somebody who's going to
live with a crippling disease and turn
them into somebody who's never even
notices the fact that was interesting
our chief medical officer had clubbed
foot and he did it's so not a part of
his life that he forgot about it until
he started working for us but like when
he was a kid he was born a foot so
that's what we're trying to do for lots
of kids around the world we're also
doing some really important work in
Hydra set in neurosurgery particularly
the treatment of hydrocephalus so our
hospital in Uganda in Bali Uganda I
don't know this for an absolute fact but
it's got to be like somewhere on the
rankings probably does more
hydrocephalus treatment in this little
outpost hospital five hours outside of
the capital it may be any place in the
world that places where a very important
treatment protocol was refined developed
where does anybody says anybody
hydrocephalus they may everybody knows
what hydrocephalus is right okay we're
out of medical school right okay so cool
okay so so yeah so now this is the part
it's funny well normally when I do this
I'm not talking to a room full of people
that are like part of a like University
sitting that's health so now i'm going
to say a bunch of things you guys
probably know so so infection in the
brain cerebrospinal fluid is going to
build up obviously causes a lot of
pressure you know crushing brain matter
I mean thankfully kids who like their
skulls haven't fully formed there had to
expand it's very shocking to see someone
like in that situation it's actually
saving their lives at that particular
moment if it's addressed quickly the
child can go on to have a completely
normal life in a surgery that takes
about 45 minutes if it's not addressed
fifty percent of those kids are going to
die before H to the other half are going
to live with very very severe
disabilities so we actually started
doing work in our hospital in Uganda
back in two thousand where we use the
standard treatment protocol which is to
put a shunt flexible tube into the head
in order to help relieve the pressure
the problem in the developing world is
that you're basically putting a time
bomb in the kids head because even
though it's really good because you save
their lives we know that that shot is
going to fail it's going to fail maybe
three to four times throughout your
lifetime and when you live 72 hours from
the closest neurosurgical facility like
it's it's good we're extending your life
we're not saving your life so we started
working with a treatment protocol with
flexible scopes called etv and then
combine that with the cotter ization of
some of the glands in the brain in order
to basically slow down the production of
fluid and we've got all these
longitudinal studies that say like we'd
argue it's a better way to treat
hydrocephalus right so the person who
authored that is now the head of
pediatric neurosurgery of boston
children's hospital they do more of
those procedures than anywhere in the
united states was about 27 we do about
950 a year at our Hospital in Uganda so
people come to Uganda to learn how to do
the procedure so suffice is so we've got
a network program where we bring
insurgents from developing countries or
we're actually training academic
pediatric neurosurgeons in the United
States in Uganda and like how to provide
this care and then send them if it
happens to be a less resource
environment we send you back to your own
country with the equipment and
partnering you with someone who actually
does follow up here so let's fight okay
so major focus is we treat a lot of
orthopedics neurosurgery that's her in
the picture on that side that's right
now a lot of reconstructive surgery from
kids have fallen fires as well as cleft
lip and palate and we also do infant
delivery and maternal care in places
like Afghanistan another thing that's
interesting about us is an organization
we've got a really strong focus on
technology and innovations so if you go
check out our website it's a great in
fact it looks a lot better on your phone
I think that even it does on the desktop
and so there's a strong focus on sort of
like leveraging technology to
communicate what we do for years we've
been one of the largest we're the
largest organization in the world that
does the kind of stuff we do and nobody
most people don't know that there's a
there's a pretty arguable statistic that
says there's about 100 million kids in
the world that have surgically
correctable conditions right so since
we're the largest provider and we don't
ever take any time to talk about it that
doesn't really help the cause of
essential surgery so we're trying to be
more intentional about that you can find
out more on our website okay so all
that's context just understand like
we're it's a it's 20 years a lot of
growth pretty quickly and not a lot of
focus actually like prior to 2010 2009
at all really on technology as first
technical person the organization they
were hired really okay so I'm going to
give you this just as a last last kind
of this isn't a feel-good story I made
as a feel-good story because it's
awesome we get a chance to help kids
like this thousands tens of thousands of
every year but this is when joy just as
a like direct example so encountered her
in june two thousand eleven i mean
obviously some severely both legs and
we're able to actually like record like
what happened before during and after
right okay so like surgical intervention
and radical impact in that kid's life it
cost us a few thousand dollars in order
to make that difference for her and her
family great pretty sophisticated from
it from an from an operating theatre
perspective if you've ever been engaged
in developing world medicine there's a
good chance you've never been someplace
like at your hospital it's a very
different sort of environment or a lot
of the stuff we treat like I have a
three-year-old nuh four-year-old I let
our docs cut my kids in a row ours like
if they had the conditions that we treat
so yeah so I talked a little bit about
like the hydrocephalus work that's
actually the guy right there been more
food pioneered that that procedure not
only we do in groundbreaking work and
hydrocephalus but like very like
significant studies in like
of foot treatment and done some stuff in
seven southern Africa on like the social
impacts of essential surgery and what
kind of impact that has on the
individual and on the family a lot of
that's been published ok so we're 1,500
employees around the world this is where
it gets tricky there's five of us on the
tech team ok so we're we're that was
five more than existed five years ago
right so that's a that's a we're dealing
with some pretty severe resource
constraints ok so back in 2011 this was
what we encountered as far as like what
we were doing from a record-keeping
standpoint right this is not that
uncommon good for us that we're keeping
medical records on everybody that were
taken care of and our Hospital in Kenya
which it existed Exodus existed now 18
years of first facility we are you know
just this giant backlog of patients and
because we're running a surgical
facility in one part of the country we
run a network of clinics around the
country where we do like long-term
identification follow up with kids that
can use the services that we provide so
this is generally how we this is our
transport layer for our fur for
information right we load these these
tubs up on top of whatever vehicle we're
going to take out to a mobile clinic and
like we dig through those records when
somebody shows up to to get it for a
follow-up appointment okay so obviously
we had a need for an EMR for some sort
of hospital information solution that
would help us solve some pretty
significant problems and we're not the
only one so there's no really good data
and actually maybe somebody in this room
knows this and if you do please come
talk to me afterwards on the question
like how many hospitals are in
underserved country low to medium like
what are categorized as low to medium
income countries there's so we took data
from the UN and wh 0 and tried to match
that up and said well we think the
number is like 14,000 but it's a lot
more than that and we actually can't
quite know that because one of the
groups working with claims they think
there's 30
in in Nigeria alone right so whatever
the number is it's significant and we're
not the only ones that are struggling
with this issue of like how to actually
implement EMR so what we did is we went
and looked into the issues of like you
know so you know what could we do like
from what we know right now related to
like Western systems so we looked at you
know Western healthcare solutions
existing open-source platforms and then
this notion of trailblazing or if we do
something else so I think it is since
given the subject everybody knows what
this is right this seven level model of
like EHR implementation in hospitals and
we asked ourselves a question like what
are we trying to get to everybody else
probably also knows that that number on
like IT staffing is either measured
based on the entire employee count or
the number of beds right and so for us
like we were looking at like traditional
solution let's assume that we don't pay
attention the fact that we're a
distributed network though we need at
least 30 to 50 additional bodies on
board to sort of like approach the
problem in a more like traditional sense
we could argue that down a little ways
and I did try to argue it down a little
ways but ultimately it falls far outside
of our meetings right so we're an
organization that like we do about 70
million dollars worth of care annually
we're raising about 22 23 million
dollars of that in the United States all
of us work like below market rate right
but at the end of the day like it just
it's not sustainable including you know
our capex expenditures on the type of
hardware we need even if someone were to
give us something for free this in case
you don't know this is about what the
average hospital if the average are all
across the entire United States is
spending on HR as a solution which falls
way outside of my budget shocker and I
would say like one of the things that's
interesting is that this is at the end
of it this charts actually like noting
what's happening from
from a venture investment in digital
health solutions right now four and a
half billion dollars is nothing right
but it's quadruple what it was just a
few years ago it's a real we all know
like health care is a really complicated
place to particularly for the software
industry to come in and like start they
actually like drive innovation but i
think it's an inevitability i mean
there's like we're going to get the
better solutions long-term so for us we
went look back at like what kind of
business requirements are we looking for
I'm not going to walk through every
single one of these bullets but most of
these things should be like should it
should be pretty obvious to a lot of us
there's we've got different requirements
than a more sophisticated facility but
they're like somewhat analogous in
ultimately we're not just tracking
patient records we actually need to
manage the business of what does it take
to deliver this care when we put in a
pharmacy order we need to make sure that
we actually have that drug on hand so
that we're not spinning our wheels
recent I'm ordering things that we don't
have and one of these items here this
we've got to sort of very specialized
requirements the solution for carrying
patient records into mobile clinics and
we've got a sustainable total cost of
ownership any questions so far I'm sort
of blazing through but nobody's asleep
yet so that's that's good okay and then
some additional business requirements we
actually we want to implement a quality
management solution and long term we've
got we need some optional support like
nursing support when you talk about
developing world health care delivery a
lot of times like for a hospital the
notion of like a nurse interacting with
an electronic system maybe like a bridge
too far but you still want to have the
opportunity to sort of grow into a
solution like that ultimately and then
we had some technical requirements we
wanted to go with a browser-based
solution because we want to not have to
install bunch of software we need the
city to continuously upgrade the system
we want to remotely monitor it we want
to measure the change management days
not weeks and months we want some
traceability on the data and what's
happening with updates we've got an
internal requirement that we use Google
as our authentication source for
everything we do so we wanted to make
sure we did that so roll through all
those just finally to say so we looked
across the potential options and it was
clear like we weren't going to move with
the commercial system we weren't going
to be able to go with an existing open
source solution based on some of these
technical and business requirements
particularly around the way the system's
hosted the way it's upgraded and then
started looking at some work we had done
previously in record keeping with the
hydrocephalus program so earlier I
talked about we do this training program
in Uganda one of the things we do when
we ship physician back out to their home
country is we equip them with a research
database that was using some pretty
innovative technology that worked even
when the Internet's off right so it's a
cloud-based solution that does this what
if we borrowed from that and actually
started thinking about a new solution
and what if we managed it more like a
product so there are some significant
challenges obviously of working in
extremely resource constrained
environments one of them's connectivity
so most of the environments that we
operate in like the low resource
environment this is in Kenya actually
which Kenya like by comparison actually
has plenty of resource is compared to
some of the places that we operate and
there's two different challenges you're
dealing with its like the reliability
the availability of the connectivity and
then the reliability once you get the
connectivity so this the optimistic part
of the presentation to say when I
started six and a half years ago at Care
International it was really really
terrible now it's just awful but it's
getting better right like five more
years from now it mean it won't be
acceptable but like will be will be
closer some of that comes from like lack
of competition there are countries
Ethiopia where the entire
telecommunications infrastructure is
managed by the government right so the
government doesn't do that well let's
not talk about whether or not the
government does anything well but like
but like the government doesn't do that
well and so there's no competitive like
landscape they shut everybody else out
it so there's not a lot of opportunity
Kenya's getting better because there's a
lot of competition but it's a definite
reality so a lot of people would
approach that and say like well since
connectivity is a problem why would you
go to the cloud we're we decided to turn
that on its head I'll talk about that a
little bit more in a minute also the
challenge of working in developing
countries so developing for us equals
shifting environments minus the
resources to support or enforce the
change so there's some pretty
significant challenges particularly as
these a lot of the government's that
we're operating in so like I'm speaking
in generalities right everybody's a
snowflake but like but the the
challenges that we encounter often are
that there's there's people looking at
like say a Western context some of the
very good decisions or you know arguably
right good decisions that are being made
there and trying to emulate those things
that's a positive not having the
resource to support that implementation
nor the resource to oversee it is the
kind of challenge that we run into it as
an organization that's trying to sort
this it's trying to play by the rules
like it's a significant significant
challenge so what's working today may
not be working tomorrow and then just
educational and workforce limitations
just as an example we opened a hospital
in nazare in 2010 and nominate anybody
know where news areas in West Africa
there's there's a river and there's a
lot of desert and then there's the
capital city and we mentor that when we
were going through the hiring process we
couldn't find a single nurse in the
country that we thought was really
qualified to work
hospital so we're investing a lot of
time and energy in training people with
raw skills but to be able to work in the
setting like to be able to provide safe
surgery in a setting like that so that's
another thing i didn't mention so we're
1,500 employees around the world less
than 100 of us are Westerners like so
this is not an organization of the West
coming to solve problems in the
developing world it's like it's a
partnership of people that are working
towards one common goal which is healing
kids so we recognize we're gonna have to
spend a lot of energy training local
nurse talent and what it means to to
operate in our facilities and do that
well which we also know means that we're
going to be feeding the local
environment because those people are
going to capture a bunch of still skills
and then move on to a job that's going
to pay them better than we will but we
we find some segments of them that are
sort of on board with the mission and so
they they choose to stay which is just
to say in a setting like that adding on
top of that now like some capacity to be
able to work with technology solutions
becomes more complicated it's equally so
when you talk about i.t talent in a lot
of these settings so it part of the
reason that we sort of dropped out and I
think part of the reason that a lot of
other open source solutions haven't
worked it is because I T talents so
valuable in a lot of these contexts so
the market may belong to me like in the
United States as someone with experience
in no time working in the technology
field it's like monumentally more for
someone who's really qualified and
capable of doing that in an environment
where there just aren't a lot of
resources a lot of people resources to
do that kind of work so the notion of
attracting that to healthcare let alone
charitable healthcare is is pretty
difficult not impossible but like very
very difficult so so that's another
constraint that you know might cause you
to curl up in a ball and decide not to
work on the problem at all and then and
then we also have the complexity of lake
in a in an environment that's like
highly
by insurance reimbursement the notion of
prescribing what someone needs to do for
the purposes of getting paid like is
like a pretty good stick right we don't
have any such scenarios I mean across
the board really I mean particularly
because we're a charitable organization
but like the insurance structures
national or private or otherwise in a
lot of these areas there exists a exists
in the short of coming online but
certainly not to the sophistication that
we have in this environment or you know
even in other single-payer systems so so
you've got another constraint here
limited financial incentives so r 4 s so
just so for connectivity developing
economies educational limitations and
then limited financial incentives but
there's some really good news at least I
see it that way it's that there's a lot
of opportunity so we've been really
focused on this like notion of Judo
flipping the constraints because we
think we got a pretty good smart people
overall not us I'm not the smart people
but like innovating as a pretty good
track record does anybody know what this
picture is this is one of the great
engineering marvels of the United States
this this it's like 1850 1860 it's the
whole process of them actually lifting
the city of Chicago in order to like
help create a sewer system you ever
wanted like this is really fascinating
green ago and I've ever want to check
this out this the city's flat and they
actually like created a grade in the
city by lifting buildings like and like
resetting them these John it's very much
like an open source project honestly
there's about six hundred people with
Jack's that are all turning one crank at
a time to lift like a portion of an inch
as they're like sort of slowly lifting
this thing it's kind of interesting that
there's actually people in the building
while they're living it they lifted
whole city blocks right so so taking the
constraints and doing something very
innovative actually some of the
techniques that were used to support
this as part of the reason we have the
pan
canal so it's actually had to build like
a whole new digging equipment in order
to like make some of this work because
they eventually reverse the river too
there's an opportunity to drive
fundamental change it's another
opportunity for this i'ma point to one
of my favorite telecommunications
technology companies on the African
continent Econet so there's a lot of
opportunity in developing world context
because that solution hasn't shown up
yet to sort of help drive the way it's
implemented right like to do things well
Eco Nets done some you know in a context
where a lot of people say it's in there
based in Zimbabwe right so I'm going to
talk about complicated economic
circumstances try running a commercially
viable telecommunications company in
Zimbabwe but they're bringing some
really interesting products to market
we're like even they bring connectivity
to your home they're actually you've got
you know these sort of like connected
home services that tie in with a health
service that they provide which will
actually not only is it doing things
like delivering health tips to pregnant
moms but also has a capacity to do
things like tying a blood pressure cuff
to like a sim card and be able to fire
that back to a physician that's able to
like help diagnose you while you're
sitting in your home so some cool
opportunities leveraging what's been
learned to define the future and then
there's an opportunity to shrink the
delivery cycle I try to put some humor
in here so one of the things we wanted
to do is create a scenario where the
point at which we noticed an issue right
so we notice a need to how we could
deliver it became very very small that's
one of the fundamental tenets of a lot
of software business and modern software
business is it's a mistake to assume
modern trends and software business or
about technology it's not it's about the
delivery cycle and access to the data so
we're trying to do is create systems
where it's possible for us to respond
quickly and do not just take your word
for it on on what you said you need but
to actually look at what you did as the
basis to define how we could help you do
that better that sounded more Big
Brother II than I meant to but I hope
you understand like like the concepts
right so there's a term in chopper
engineer we say users lie and that's
true some butt so we also saw a big
opportunity to be able to make usability
the number one priority so in a setting
where you're dealing with extreme
resource constraints we're not in a
setting where like if we if we launch
into an EMR implementation it's not
going well there's no cavalry that's
going to come in and help us consult our
way out of the problem like we it's
either it's going to sink or swim based
on like the plan that we've got the
resources we put around it initially and
just the quality of the product so we're
hoping not to build teapots that will
burn you there's also an opportunity to
like capture some really significant
data so this is the data analysis tool
that we use on a regular basis in order
to like measure trends around what's
happening on our website we're
integrating that exact same experience
into Ospital run is the solution
actually it's based the engineering team
for this is based right here in Portland
and then finally I think finally we are
we really want to embrace a concept in
that's becoming more and more popular in
modern software development which is
called offline first development so in
my industry we've been really lazy for a
while and because basically there's
ubiquitous connectivity we just build
everything with the assumption that
there's that you're always connected the
reality is like we're dealing with
constraints where we have to assume that
you have connectivity sometimes but
where there are could be significant
periods measured in minutes potentially
hours at times or you don't have
connectivity and the argument actually
like across the software industry is
that we should be trending
more towards this as a pattern because
the reality is we've all experienced
that moment that you go into the subway
and then all the sudden your phone
doesn't work on something that seems
like it should have been like completely
functional obviously you can't assume
you can connect to the internet but why
is my appt breaking why does it treat
offline as an error condition so great
news modern browsers have both
frameworks and tools built directly into
the browser that will help you do this
well and we've got about five years of
experience by six years of experience
doing that kind of work and then the
biggest thing this one and I'm really
passionate about this comes from a talk
a couple years ago that guy happens to
be on our board but the focus was like
what can we as technologists do to give
people back their time right so by
building systems that are easier to use
would it be possible that you'd actually
like offer people back the only thing
that we can't make more of and we think
there is some good opportunity to be
able to do that and we're plumbing the
system actually in order to be able to
measure that okay so this is the talent
portion of the presentation so I'm going
to share a couple technical details
around the open source solution that
we're we're working with okay so first
of all this is the homepage for hospital
run I would encourage you to go check it
out as a project it may be tweet about
it because maybe maybe you want to get
involved because lots of people to be
involved maybe you know somebody wants
to get involved so hospital and I oh and
we're embracing both that usability
piece as well as it offline first
functionality okay so I'm this is test
data that I've sort of modified in my
development environment but like this is
an example of like what we've got in the
patient screen and there's some really
cool things that are going on with
two-way data-binding where all the
information I shouldn't have said that
I'm sorry I said the word two-way data
binding and I talk like this anyway so
so there's some really interesting
things that are going on with the way
we're capturing this
data catalog and presenting it and this
feature actually what we're doing with
patient history and like in clinical
notes comes directly from feedback that
we had from our very first deployment
Philippines just another example of like
a few of the screens it's the slide
where section the system so searching
through appointments looking through the
list of admitted patients another
patient edit screen with coding for
congenital clubfoot so this it just as a
so how do we do this from a technical
deployment perspective that this is
where like sort of it's possible to use
the technology in order to do something
really interesting so this is this is
the nerdiest slide I'll have this one in
the next one this is kind of like the
core set up that we use when we're
deploying hospital run as a solution so
you've got all these endpoints that are
interacting with the system and then
what we actually have is an appliance
computer that's running internally in
the environment like so pretty pretty
low grade hardware relatively that
actually is running the system and then
outside the firewall we've got a cloud
instance that it's connected to and we
use a piece of technology that
automatically gives us the data
replication over secure lines and then
we also have the capacity to integrate
with things like a pack service because
of the offline first nature all these
systems are actually the ones that are
running hospital run so as I as I
download the system the very first time
I've actually got access to kind of the
entire the entire breadth of
functionality in the system and so the
whole way the system is actually built
is so that if I'm connected to the
Internet I'm always talking to the
server whatever the server means if I'm
outside of the facility that's the cloud
service if I'm inside the facility it's
the appliance service I don't really
understand like what the difference is
my machine doesn't need to know anything
about where I'm actually at and then if
I lose connectivity entirely I can
actually use the offline first
capabilities
in order to still interact with records
does that kind of make sense because as
a concept okay and then just a couple
more things here the the early results
so like what have we actually done with
a solution like this so far the stars
mark the places where we've done
deployments and the Philippines we
actually we've launched the entire
system so we're at a state right now
from an open source project perspective
where we haven't officially called it
like a 10 version where we're
encouraging lots of other people to
start using it but we're using our
hospital network as kind of the guinea
pigs I have the advantage of running an
open source project right directly
connected users who more or less have to
do what I asked them to do and getting
pretty favorable responses back so far
and just this week we we have a partner
who launched it in eight hospitals in
Guinea knowing that it kind of wasn't we
don't think it's ready for primetime yet
but where they wanted to start capturing
user feedback they've got the resources
possible to do it so just to say like
we're kind of picking up momentum from
from an open source project perspective
we've done about a thousand patient
records at our hospital in the
Philippines so I mean these are
relatively small facilities you know
doing you know somewhere between
thousand and two thousand procedures per
year and that's all I had to share about
that so if you guys have questions you
like to talk about like some of those
challenges the constraints maybe what
we're doing is a project I'm happy to
talk about this thing so thanks very
much this is pretty exciting stuff for
those of us who have been implementing
expensive vendor EA charge for a long
time it's nice to see something actually
moving along in this space in that
regard there's within the u.s. there's
about 700 critical access hospitals in
rural communities that are all facing
bankruptcy right now yeah with huge IT
expenses that they can't maintain do you
foresee a time when you could take your
your product and start implementing it
in resource-constrained areas of the
United States yeah so
um sure because because there's a lot of
things that could happen in the future
one of the things we're really focused
on is like is making sure our product
management is very tight for like so a
lot of open source projects projects
tend to operate as like a giant
do-gooding activity and that's good like
there's been a lot of really positive
work that's going on with that
developers tend to only contribute to
things that help developers but once you
get past that and you can how to build
some momentum one of the mistakes i
think that's happened with previous
attempts like this is that there's been
sort of too broad of a focus initially
so we're going to build a health system
that could replace a commercial platform
now what that's kind of too big of a
time to bite off getting to the place
where a solution like this was feasible
for a more for the United States I would
say like it's certain anything's
possible it's not really a focus of the
project right now but yeah I mean I i
think my bigger hope would be if we were
really successful at what we did it
would drive innovation from more
resource companies in in markets that
are like this already so yeah yeah yeah
so to what extent are you building in
international healthcare
interoperability standards such as
icd-10 and others into this yeah so the
system's actually it's plumbed actually
it's got a really nice interface for how
you interact a least we think so as a
clinician interacting with icd-10
particularly actually like we we
borrowed some technology that is used in
the Twitter type-ahead in order to like
basically be able to consume and digest
the entire coding standard and do
pattern matching like as you're typing
it through the system so we're trying to
create some scenarios where like
actually doing accurate
voting is not painful it isn't require
you to click through six or seven
different screens nor does it require a
ton of setup work so I'm going to make a
point that isn't about your point but
one of the big things we're focused on
is like what could we do to help support
one changing change agent in a facility
to like get people on board with the
notion that like we ought to be storing
this data electronically and so one of
the things that requires is like sort of
this product development perspective
that says like you need to be able to
lock things down long-term but in the
near term actually people just want to
start using the system they don't want
to populate 100 type fields in order to
just like sort of enter the first
patient record so we've got a lot of
those types of its it's meant to sort of
drop the friction in the onboarding
process and then allows you to turn
around in the administrative panel and
say okay we're not letting people edit
that more like we're going to clarify
we're out with the data and now we're
ready to like get more sophisticated so
anyway we're we've got a strong focus on
being able to particularly when it comes
to coding be able to implement those
types of standards of course it gets
complicated depending on the environment
like the the which version of icd-10
you're like using can change and so I
would say honestly like we're still
sorting out like some of those issues
but it works actually really really well
right yes sir I guess this piggy backs a
little bit on that I have two questions
the first one is are you adhering to
kind of internationally accepted data
standards like hl7 or fire or anything
like yeah yeah and then the second
question is going back you had a slide
in there about deciding whether or not
to use a commercial solution versus an
open source yeah obviously openmrs has
had some success and has been deployed
in different areas where can you speak
to why you decided in how solution is
better than taking something that
or an alternative open source solution
because it wasn't in house like so we're
driving right we're leading an open
source project that's what like so this
would be a giant failure if we're the
only people that ever utilize it which
is one of the reasons we're encouraged
by the fact that more people are
onboarding yeah so like I've happening
in to that question so I always want to
make sure like I'm careful like so I am
NOT interested in bashing work somebody
else's done I think there's a lot of
good people doing good work on openmrs I
think that the fact that the project is
existed for more than a dozen years and
this is still a gigantic problem might
demonstrate that that the problems more
than just building a piece of software
that the issue is actually more about
the entire onboarding process and
actually creating an open-source service
that it be possible for anybody to like
have access to right so if you're you
know permission the appropriate way so I
think like part of the issue with
deployments like that one there's like
they have a hallmark of being built by
engineers who didn't care about
usability which we're seeing across the
industry like that used to be okay in
1996 and if you're a company that does
things like that eventually the markets
going to eat you up because someone's
going to figure out not only a cheaper
way to deliver it but a way where you
actually get the lower level users
clamoring order to get access to that
solution so usability is a pretty
significant issue but the actual
mechanics of how a solution like that is
installed and administered an upgraded
long term is another sort of systemic
reason we decided it wasn't we looked
into the notion of like could we count
walk into that community and help push
it forward in a way that we thought was
better and ultimately determine like the
friction there was just going to be like
two significant I mean particularly when
it comes to the offline first
requirement so if you solutions like
that tend to walk away from the cloud
because of that connectivity issue
rather than accommodate for it in the
way the designs implemented and so we're
sort of thinking at a at a root level
that that's one of the core things we
want to embrace which is it should work
even when the Internet's off but we
would like you to actually host it on
the internet so or on some sort of
private cloud so yeah that makes sense
yeah yeah so it's really great talk it
sounds like great work I really enjoy
sort of the you know that this cloud
based approach and it seems like things
are very streamlined and user-oriented
and that kind of thing I was wondering
for you know us a lot of us being
researchers in informatics you know when
we look at the the you know spate of
problems that's out there some of them
can be solved by something that's just a
simple reorienting of how you think
about something or focusing on on users
or something like that I'm wondering if
you think there are also remaining
challenges that are sort of like big
challenges that researchers might need
to tackle but our but are still have a
significant impact right so that there's
so it's not just you know this is this
was a big problem but you know all it
needed was this different perspective
and different solution yeah is there are
there still challenges that are like
this is a this is a significant thing
that we need to get some some research
yeah
okay so that's a big question that so
I'm going to say something makes me
sound like a more of an expert about
this topic than I am so for us I think
one of the like challenges is like
long-term like a deeper level
instrumentation like in like integration
with a lot of the devices that we're
working with not just in capturing the
data off those devices so you know so
the blood pressure cup or whatever right
so that it's not for us like one of the
one of the big challenges that are out
there is like is maintenance and repair
of a lot of those items becomes a pretty
pretty significant challenge and there's
a lot more that if those devices were
sort of built in a way that that was
able to sort of make other systems aware
of their like health their help that
would be a big benefit particularly for
organizations that are working in pretty
resource constrained environments for us
I mean a common thing when you see it
like very very very commonly is that
great equipment gets shipped someplace
but nobody's there who really knows how
to take care of it or like or there's
there's sort of no like internal
capability in a lot of those pieces of
equipment to tell people like when there
actually is a problem so I think that's
kind of a big challenge for us I don't
know if I was helpful some curious some
when you're deploying your solutions are
you targeting clinicians patients or
both and when you do so are there any
particular constraints that come to mind
in addition to having to develop for
offline services as well yeah so our
strong focus so there's a couple
different like in our industry like
actors that we think about we're so when
we talk about usability like we're
talking about ease of use for clinicians
for administrators for support staff
ease of deployment ultimately actually
one of the things we're trying to do too
is make it easy for developers to
contribute code to it so we made some
very intentional technology choices
about how the systems built in order to
enable that but one of the big
challenges so it's it's more its
position focus not like patient-focused
really is like that's sort of the short
answer on on that one of the big
challenges you know that we have this
always security like so it's you know
data secure you're walking into a whole
different world of complexity when you
start talking about so there's some
trade-off I need the capability to carry
records out into a remote clinic
location but I'm now created more attack
area from a like security perspective on
data right now so that's like one of
those big challenges that like we are
walking forward with some like some
smart decisions including the
determination that you can just decide I
don't want any of the offline sirs of
services to work on the system I like
we're going to just use it internally in
this facility but I think that's like
probably one of the biggest one of the
biggest challenges
guys given to not only making it a
system that's going to be good for
clinicians to use so they can access all
the data but also it's more of like a
data or like a research kind of data
warehouse yeah where you can actually
take the data that you're collecting
over the years and say okay this is what
we did five years ago this is what we're
doing now our outcomes have improved by
this amount yeah I mean so the
technology we're using for for data
storage creates a lot of opportunity for
that and it's part of one of it's also
one of the reasons why we went with a
solution like this that that capacity to
be able to roll information up in an
obviously transformed like totally
different more consumable form is one of
the focuses of the project it's not a
feature in the system at the moment but
it's a big focus of the project could
you tell us a little bit about the
evaluation of the project are there
people actually doing that I mean
obviously there's good uptake but then
once a hospital has implemented is there
a plan for evaluating success yeah
developing yes there's a plan developing
so there's two different actually two
different connection points right now
we're at a stage like so in our open
source project we're looking to deploy
in our existing hospitals as well as
starting to work with a select set of
beta cos basically beta customers for
the solution specifically because
developing that evaluation plan is one
of the tasks that we have in front of us
before we'd say like hey we think
anybody be like should give this a try
that's part of it but i also think part
of part of focus on a cloud-based
solution is that we're we're actually
plumbing the system with the kind of in
application analytics that helps us
evaluate things like what our users
getting stuck on how much time is it
taking them
to accomplish task X in the system and
we can actually we can measure that
information and judge ourselves even
release / release on those types of
things so there's definitely an
interview like there's an interview
piece and an evaluation of like data
quality that needs to find its way into
the project there's also a lot we can do
from a technology perspective to let you
talk to us without talking to us yeah
just a couple of questions I was
interested to know in the most likely
when you looked at it the commercial
solutions so not including mrs just by
the very nature of their costs and you
know both in terms of actual money and
resources required to implement it they
were probably off the table immediately
but i was interested to know just from
your other requirements where what they
fell short on and how you didn't feel
like they would fit what you needed yeah
so there's a comedy a lot of it actually
was was based on the type of hardware
that we'd have to be able to support in
in the facilities so we didn't have the
capacity to be able to take care of that
fact we had a we had a really generous
offer from an organization back 34 years
ago where they were going to give us
their software license free but it was
going to cost us about a quarter million
dollars per location in like hardware
installation which not was not an
unreasonable is a very generous thing to
offer and we were going to put you know
it's not a refrigerator right i mean
software is like it's not a thing we
just plug it in and then it works
forever like it's a living breathing
activity so they're a couple other so
easy use and a lot of the features the
amount of training was going to take for
us to get to a place where we felt like
our staff was comfortable working with
some of those solutions and we didn't
feel like we felt like that was a little
cost prohibitive as well and then as
we've got people transitioning in and
out do we have resources locally that
like you're going to be able to help
manage that process and then
trying to run where there was a third
thing but anyway you get kind of the
point yeah yeah maybe the last thing I
would ask is you know for the for the
group that this is at people since this
is an open source project if there was
interest in people getting involved what
are they sort of major areas of need
that you could see people helping fill
at this point I'd remember what my third
thing was here but then also that um the
third thing was actually so it's this
there's a trap you can fall into when
there are some there are some sectors of
business problems that technology
companies are sort of like transferable
across the board like customer
relationship management is the same
thing no matter where you are when you
talk about like someone giving you a
piece of software that wasn't designed
to work in your environment your
capacity to influence the roadmap of how
that software continues to get built is
like zero right so as we need countered
issues where we felt like hey we really
need the system to do this there's no
chance that that's ever going to happen
so not only is the release cycle for
that you know six to 12 to 18 months but
also we wouldn't have a voice ever so
that was actually the other issue so one
of the things I encourage if folks are
interested in even just checking out the
project go to website from there you'll
find a link to our github repo I'm not
asking you guys to write code it's
moving to if you want to join our slack
channel or our slack there's actually a
subsection of people that that come from
more of a practitioner background that
are starting to sort of like track with
what's happening from the feature
development perspective in the project
to be able to provide input long-term
we've got actually some needs around
like sort of developing an
implementation plan right so we hope
there's a lot of things that we're
building that are like pretty apparent
but the reality is like helping people
plan to be successful these and things
is work that we're as now say so it's
sort of two separate things Hospital
enters a project Care International is
an organization that
incubating this project we're investing
resources in doing that but we love more
help so that would be a big area
assistant okay yeah thanks thanks to pay
attention
you